hey clatter fans it's episode a special
episode of rule of two an unboxing for
an Anakin Skywalker hot toys figure is
that correct given here to my partner in
crime mark Fernandez aka mark Sidious
what do we got here mr. Fernandez so our
great friends over at Sideshow
Collectibles yeah they gave me this
thing yeah okay
it's a Anakin Skywalker full-on Sith
with the red eyes
post dark yeah it started right all
right so here we go I can't wait to see
this thing
just kind of lift up the top here
careful Shh
they're some of the facts steam coming
out of it
picture the Imperial March plane right
now and you look nice look at that it
looks like a lightsaber in action that
you can use let's start with the base so
the base oh yeah those little like
that's sustained as in Star Wars
Galaxies you can actually get this as a
vehicle and it's the only way to travel
around in the in the lava oh that's
great little touch great little touch
we're going to remove the Anakin
yet you're shorter than I expected look
at the detail on these boots like those
are some game boots those boots
so things are getting started now so we
got Anakin's hand which is fully you can
fully articulate it which is really cool
every little knuckle every knuckle look
at the detail on that that's really cool
so then you also get Anakin's gloved
hand holding the lightsaber with the
famed hilt you also get one two three
four five six hands this is when he
closes the door behind
oh that's awesome
hell yeah look at that we're getting
close here boys and girls
so it looks like wielding never seemed
that before in a hot toy that's
something I've never seen before
all right let's pose this puppy
[Music]
I mean that's pretty badass dude what do
you think about that writing yeah is
that rule of two worthy
that's rule of two worthy look at that
oh yeah
[Music]
thank you to sideshow thank you to Star
Wars thank you to Hayden Christensen
thank you to you thank you thank you to
the fans yeah subscribe leave some
comments share this video and head on
over to Jedi Council podcast feed for
our latest rule of two and hit us up at
Riley around at Mark Fernandez 76 and
then Anakin